hey this is Labe I'm here in the studios
of aj+ this is the language of today you
know the Prophet Muhammad was given a
Quran because poetry was kind of what
was popping in the Raven hood so this is
the way that we communicate now everyone
from girls would like body shaming
issues should I vote for Bernie or not
abortion teenage pregnancy it's opened
up a way for people to ask and that's
really why God in the social media I and
others who were mentioned pose a threat
because we undermine the very path those
that Islam in the West are incompatible
who concerns you more right now Isis or
Donald Trump I get death threats from
the far right much more frequently than
I do from Isis
one of our major legal axioms is an
artful mock em which means culture is a
decider and that really gave a lot of
license for interpretation in a sense of
how culture flows through the religion
religion doesn't necessarily try to
close a culture down how you package it
I mean if you want to if you want to
spit bars like Jericho do it if in those
big bars like a dot do it if you want to
be like nas you do it it doesn't care
about that right it cares about the
message not necessarily the package